[Music]
there's been a bunch of announcements
already if you've been watching the
keynotes ACP he's got a lot of attention
promise we without going into all the
detail frankly I am actually doing a
speech tomorrow afternoon talking about
where we are technology wise and
platform wise with SCB so come to that
one bring your friends but so without
going into all that detail all I'll say
is is we've come a long way in twelve
months so nine months ago at next San
Francisco last year we launched the four
terabyte servers and with a promise that
we'd have the 12 terabytes this year and
then the 18 terabytes obviously we
announced yesterday we've made the 12
terabytes available to early access
customers that's just a huge move
forwards the only 12 terabyte VMs in
market the largest VMs in market we
really are setting the pace for the
industry at this point and then from our
customer perspective I have to tell you
the my objective here was not just to go
out and randomly take anyone my
objective was look I've been in this
market a long time what happens
generally for SUV customers is they come
to you and say well I know you have a
customer that's like me but I'm bigger
than them and so are you really can you
handle me right and so that was one of
our challenges as we came in the market
was the how do you how do you convince
this market that were serious about sa P
and that we can handle everybody without
this taken five years for us to build
and so objective number one for me was
let's not just go find anyone let's take
the largest customers that we can find
and let's convince them that a Google
cloud the Cirrus and B we can run their
STP environments and we did that as
you're about to see we've rolled out a
bunch of names already more to come over
time but we got some of the largest
customers on the planet two of which are
represented here today and that would be
the second part which is the extended
part of the strategy frankly is that I
thoroughly believe that SCP customers
don't actually buy from salespeople that
SUV customers are a giant Club and they
buy from each other right one of them
does something and if it's successful
they tell all the friends and all the
friends choose to do it too
and so objective number one was fighting
the largest customers on the planet and
convinced them to come to Google Cloud
objective number two was letting them
tell their stories and so that's today's
subject is let's bring two customers up
on stage to tell their story of what
they're doing with ACP and Google Cloud
so you can learn from them and and hear
it from you know hear it from the
customers mouth instead of from our
mouths so with that I'd like to walk
onstage
Meena Kishan Chandani I got it right
this time all right both times
apparently Meena who is with McKesson
technology and quinoa salt cider from
metronome or Metro group okay okay I
know I had a little bit of a fall last
night so so I need some more time to
walk yeah hold the mic
yeah Meena I got I got a an email last
night for me no they said I fell in the
I fell last night trying to get into the
lift and I might not make it there I'm
like whew that's ungood so I honestly
appreciate you appreciate you making the
effort
I will also qualify by the way that Mina
said I hadn't rung any alcohol at the
time there was no need to qualify but
she did qualify when she arrived today
exactly because I thought that's the
natural question that comes to I assume
nothing I only had concerns so really
quickly first of all both of you thank
you for giving us time today you've
actually both been very generous with
your time
both here and previously they said it's
one of the one of the great things for
me about SCP is it is a giant community
where the customers all do work with
each other equally Google is very good
at that community and you've both given
time gracefully and gratefully already
so really do appreciate what you do for
us that said generally I will say that
the in any SCP project technology is
part of it and we're Google cloud we
like to talk about technology but a lot
of this is about people right it's about
people leading and it's about people as
a group changing so I think people
become important so instead of just
piling into technology can we get a
little background from you
you know what's your career history how
do you get here what's your current role
what are you doing so we get a sense of
you sure so I have been with McKesson
for about a dozen years now and prior to
that I was based out of Midwest working
for a utility company as a database
architect so that's that's what my
background is and then when I joined
McKesson I joined as a database
architect and ap technology team
essentially a basis team and not having
any background in s AP whatsoever in
fact the first day I joined McKesson I
looked around and I just said ask people
what's the AP basis you know so that's
where I started in asipi but very
quickly within you know within a year I
kind of crossed over to the SP area and
kind of grew through that for in that
technology space and then over time I've
had a lot of opportunities at McKesson
and then I've led the SP technology
teams there and most and then along the
way about also took over actually some
data analytics responsibilities and
stood up a service with in McKesson
on-prem started we started some cloud
expansion work on that front as well and
that continues to go on very recently
I've transitioned everything I
previously had and and now my role is
just purely to focus on our ERP
transformation in North America and also
to support our European your ERP journey
as well they've already started on us
for but so but primarily that's going to
be my focus going forward so no pressure
you're only responsible for the entire
operating environment of McKesson for
the future if you put it that way you're
delivering it yeah no it's it's it's a
team it's a very very large and talented
not large I should say it's a very very
talented team it's not as large as it
needs to be
but no it is it's it's all the team
thanks
I'm the chief solution officer at Metro
and actually like that title quite a lot
because a second title is chief
information officer so after
organization I have a chief solution
officer represents a bit more what I'm
doing because I'm not only in charge of
IT but also on product and user
experience so that means I run the
entire product organization within Metro
we are pretty large within my
organization or two and a half thousand
people purely an IT and UX etc and I'm
in this role now since almost two years
so I'm pretty new before that I was
basically only in the digital space or
building a lot of tools and products are
probably not known here in the US but
for example Singh that's a European
version of LinkedIn so I was there also
in the supervisory board so a lot of
digital background started actually
computer science here around the corner
in Berkeley so I feel a bit home just a
bit actually and yeah doing this as I
said for two years now and we're in the
middle of the digital transformation and
I think that's the reason why Metro
approached me and asked what I would
like to work for this organization
because one of my tasks is obviously to
drive and we'll talk I think in a minute
about Metro itself but ICP I mean we are
a german-based company and as German
company you have to have some er s AP so
they're probably using s AP mainly in
the financial sector there are some
changes without pulling too much into
the state's direction because I have the
feeling that some ICP salespeople are
chase me around the globe because it
might be that we is also introduced ICP
retail in the near future because so far
we have custom-developed solution
running our merchandising environment
but yeah we are an SI p shop when it
comes to finance and I think that's the
reason why I'm sitting here yeah I mean
just I think really the next question is
just to set the scale because I think
Metro is a metros effectively everywhere
in the world except us brand the fact
that if you were chasing through right
now
giant retail and you guys were number
two and you just split into two
companies right before that actually the
number two retailer in Europe so you
just want to give the audience just a
perspective on who Metro is and the
scale you operate at okay don't wanna go
to back in history because I mean we are
67 years old company had really a huge
footprint
we decide now to focus very very strong
so the focus is now really on our core
business which is wholesale so that
means we are wholesale company acting in
35 countries around the globe not in the
US as you just mentioned but we are very
strong in Europe and very strong and
agents or emerging markets for us are
China India for example we are very
strong and obviously in our home base in
Germany we are pretty strong but also in
France and Italy in Spain and Russia
etcetera so 35 countries and it's a
pretty big organization so we have 37
billion revenue currently euro so around
38 billion u.s. dollars and we have
150,000 people so and in also very
exotic mark markets like Myanmar or
Pakistan etcetera so therefore it's
usually quite hard for me to get into US
because I have this time from Pakistan
in my my passport and it's not it's not
that easy to get into the country but
yeah so pretty big organization and
whole food is our core business and
coming obviously from brick-and-mortar
and my responsibilities not to move this
into the omni-channel world
so therefore invest quite heavily
currently into online shops and apps and
all this kind of stuff though I mean
effectively you are for the u.s.
audience in the room you the business
model for you at this point it's
effectively your Costco right your dude
well you would argue you've existed a
long time before Costco did but you the
equivalent business in the u.s. yeah so
Costco Cisco so these are the
equivalents here in the US the problem
we are facing is as I said we're on
different countries and we've running
unfortunately not one business model
which would be great from an IT
perspective but in some countries it's
more b2c business where in other
countries of classical b2b business and
mainly restaurants hotels caterers these
are our classical customers and as I
said we're running different business
models and that makes it extremely hard
because we have a central IT serving
these more than 30 countries with
different business models and that makes
it very complex to standardize and but
that's one of the reasons why we focus
very much on SP because there's a
sustain of solution and we want to
simplify our process landscape Thanks
Meena McKesson is again McKesson so
fascinating coming four to six six
largest company in America and it's
amazing the number of people I meet you
say exactly yeah so as you mentioned
it's a fortune six company with
news of close to I think 210 billion and
it's been in business for over I think
185 years I don't know exact number by
now who's counting but so we primarily
uh you know deliver basically one-third
of prescription medicines in North
America are delivered by McKesson then
we also have a pretty large offering in
our brand and private label of medical
surgical supplies then we operate in the
specialty healthcare space as well
supporting Oh upwards of I think 9,000
plus oncologists and specialists
throughout our networks and then we also
offer we also support a large number of
independently owned and banner
pharmacies as well we we are about from
employee strength perspective I think we
are about seventy eight thousand plus at
the moment and we operate across 16
countries right now so yeah I guess give
you a perspective on McKesson I think
even inside Google when we started
working with McKesson a lot of people
were like oh we're McKesson what do you
do just because I used to call on
McKesson with my SUV badge on back in
the days but the question I always put
two people who fiend just imagine this
is so I'll think about your local horse
with all your local doctors office
chocolate Ennis officers who understand
all the consumables they go through
every day right in terms of sealing bags
and gloves and needles and everything
they need and then question if you've
never question that wonder why is there
not a giant warehouse attached to those
hospitals and the simple answer is there
isn't because McKesson is that warehouse
I mean for eight hours a day pretty much
every hospital box office they in this
office whatever calls McKesson and says
I need these things tomorrow or in the
next 40 hours and it goes I mean and
this is part of the well I went to
reinforce it's not just the scale of
these two customers and who they are and
what we're taking on here but also the
the reliability
crucially where the reliability and
performance are everything right if if
metro stops working there's a lot of
restaurants that just don't work it and
there's a lot of people frankly that
don't eat because of it
if McKesson stops working operations get
cancelled
we have huge issues you know hospitals
don't keep the supplies in stock they
look at their schedule and the order to
your operation having been scheduled
right so when people come back and go
well is the cloud ready this isn't just
a it's a little site accounting system
we're talking serious economic impact
and challenge if we don't do it right
right this is a huge step for us
absolutely what comes to mind is you
know a couple of years ago we had a
leadership conference here and our CEO
kind of gave us came to you know talk to
us and somebody asked him what's what
are your top most priority is that I IT
can be working on and he kind of just
looked point-blank at us he's like don't
break anything and don't let anyone
steal anything so that's our expectation
of Google as well that's mistakes for us
yeah because those operations excellence
is a huge you know part of our culture
and that's very very important to us
don't steal anything was in reference
the data yes you're so have a huge
amount of data or no pressure no
pressure on me anyway so thanks for that
equally the other thing I think is
fascinating here is two industries
healthcare and retail where you know
these are not industries should go to to
retire in effectively right these are
not these are industries that are a
massive change globally in that I think
that leads us into the conversation too
which is you know this time last year a
lot of the conversation I got was lift
in shift lift and shift right we just
need to lift and shift what we have and
and moved in the cloud and I think in
both of your cases there is no lifted
shift here right the we're talking
massive projects and along the way your
business in your industry is changing
rapidly and so you have to deal with
that change as well do you want to just
quickly highlight the you know what
keeps you awake at night in that context
yeah obviously I mean health care is
such a rapidly changing you know it's
rapid scale you know it's becoming
increasingly high-tech and very SAP you
know tech savvy also a consumers are
demanding more they have a lot more
power and then we have a large set of
aging population across the globe and
then and then you have these government
agencies and regulators constantly
constantly changing the rules and
policies on us so you have to be able to
you know quickly adapt and to those
changes and quickly deliver those those
to those requirements do so IT has can
have a pretty large impactful role to
enable our our business to be able to
meet those demands so yep so the change
is constant and that's what we are
seeing continuously and that's where we
need to focus on you know modernizing
architectures to be able to meet the
needs of the business demands and team
of retail is yeah reach there was an
easy life these days right not much
change going on yeah absolutely
no in fact we are facing huge issues in
front of us so I think in the past it
was quite easy I mean you just saw do
stuff and you're all set
these days things aren't changing
radically so and if you look in
particular all markets if you look into
Asia I mean I think a lot of innovation
out of Ritter is coming in the meantime
out of China so for example usage of
mobile devices in China is completely
different than in Europe and I also
believe you in the u.s. so it's pretty
normal that I know 80 year old women
gets to a store and she having her
mobile phone and paying with a mobile
phone and scanning product etcetera so
that's pretty normal so the speed of
innovation pushed out of these markets
or and competitors like Ali Baba's or
long-term competitors or Amazon I mean
that they're pushing hard into that
direction you bring a lot of innovation
to that space and for us we really try
to be an omni-channel player so
therefore we have this brick and mortar
business huge stores around the globe
and what we need to do is obviously
drive our customers a bit more into this
omni-channel world and this makes it
quite difficult also coming also from or
b2c background I just figure out that
obviously the customer behavior is
completely different in our world so
it's not that customers are searching
for a product if a restaurant owner gets
to into our stores he or she knows
exactly what they're looking for
so therefore a complete different
customer behavior they don't want to
spend too much time in the store so they
want to obviously get in and get out as
fast as possible with the best prices
and the best customer experience I so
therefore optimizing for example the
checkout process the cashier is one of
the topics we have will bring a lot of
technology currently in so a lot of also
AI technology like vision API said Sarah
tries to detect products also running a
lot of innovation when it comes to
augmented reality so you take your
mobile phone and put it on a product and
then you get some additional information
on the product so this kind of topics
are brand new to our world and obviously
this is a huge change of the now
internal processes and also on the
mindset so when it comes to agility and
I don't know self organized teams etc
these are the topics and we as I said
we're a pretty old organization and if
you want to transform the organization
into a very fast high speed organization
this is also one of the challenges it
keeps me awake come back to that one in
a second so I wasn't joking at the start
where I said the old answer is for me
the answer was let's get the biggest
customers we can unless proven we can do
this both of you represent on the stage
at STP do you want to just kind of give
people the sense on statistically where
you write with your STP installations so
we are running not only one asipi
installations we're running multiple as
I said we have this decentralized
environment so what we're doing
currently with s AP and in context on on
Google cloud is that we are
consolidating more than 100 different
accounting systems so and you just heard
that are saying we have 25 or 30
countries and you might ask yourself ok
25 or 30 countries by run hundred
different accounting systems so
consolidation of these systems is quite
hard for us and we expect that this
project will take three to five years to
consolidate all these systems if you
look in the cost Center infrastructures
or the numbers of customers we have
across the globe are more than 10,000 so
to constantly date them into a couple of
hundred it's already a big challenge so
this is where we are and we started this
whole journey about 12 months ago where
I said ok let's let's look how we how
the future of our I said insulation will
be and we have the general strategy to
move towards clouds or we're doing this
obviously not only in s IP road but also
in our additional initiatives when it
comes to online service etc but now we
are in the middle of that journey and
it's pretty clear that we're moving into
sa ps4 Hana and claw on
Google cloud and this is where we are
right now and yeah project just thought
about a couple of months ago we still in
a conceptual phase and currently very
close to bring the first country life
and then obviously continue with rolling
out there a solution to all of the rest
of the countries yeah I mean it's a huge
project
it's funny when we published an article
about you and the number of phone calls
I got from SCP people and customers who
came back and said wait that bar has to
be a typo that article says there are
more than a hundred individual SCB
systems historically was completely
decentralized in their consolidating
into one and we're for the record
there's only two customers I know of
globally that are doing this you're one
of them there's there's another one
that's not public is doing this but I
mean it is a manin with all the stuff we
just talked about changing your industry
the complexity that's involved in doing
all of those changes and bringing them
all together and inevitably I think
maybe I'm wrong but my perspective on
your project like for a lot of people
you start this project with a
destination it's unlikely to be the
actual destination you end up that right
because the world's going to change in
the mean time and so a lot of what
hopefully we're doing for you know where
you need is the flexibility right it's
the it's the misunderstanding the the
there is no set destination and the
ability to change rapidly at all layers
and the stack is what's gonna get you
where you need to get to is that fair
yeah so of scalability flexibility so
these are the key words first obviously
we're also interested at nobody stealing
stuff from us but frankly this is a core
requirement on our site so and we really
want to do much more and therefore
coolest for its not only a strategic
partner when it comes to our finance I
say P world it's also an overall
strategic partner so we long-term we
plan to move basically everything into
the cloud so that's a clear strategy
here and therefore there's a high demand
also when it comes to cultural aspects
collaboration innovation these kind of
topics with s AP and Google and
therefore we're pushing out on these
topics but you're right it's a very
complex process this will take as I said
a couple of years to finalize that one
and the biggest challenge is not only
technology also convince the people that
is the right way to go so I have a lot
of CFO sitting in the countries telling
me that this is a pretty stupid idea
that they want to sit on their existing
processes in infrastructure and
therefore we need to convince also these
kind of people making sure that
everybody is following the same path but
standardization and harmonization and
simplification of the processes business
your target of Mitchell Mina you want to
run the statistics package on yeah yeah
it's it's you know it's considered as so
I think amongst the top three or five or
something like that so it's a pretty
large install base that we have of s ap
across Europe and North America
we probably close to I want to say maybe
thirty plus products that you know that
are either deployed or on their way to
be deployed and a and probably close to
upwards of two hundred and sixty SP
instances that we have and I'm sure
every day the number changes and one of
our largest production systems no no
sorry non production but I you know I'll
talk about why the non production is
also important because in North America
one of our ECC instances it's upwards of
hundred terabytes and when you think
about the entire landscape and most of
them except for development is a copy of
production so you're talking like big
scale and if you're talking about cloud
I mean that's just not gonna you know
that's just impossible to you know move
lift and shift and also that system
currently you know supports transaction
volumes close to if I think about peak
lines it's close to I want to say to you
know close to two million line items a
day and and that to most of the
processing is done within the four to
six hour peak peak time and then
availability I think you know it's
almost like a 24 by 7 requirement which
we don't we're not we're not achieving
that but because we do have some
maintenance windows on the weekend a
very short one which now the business we
are getting a lot of pressure to
eliminate that so we will be looking to
Google to help us with that and then be
also very very large HANA shop we've had
HANA
deployed in our environment up for I
think since 2014 it's probably one of
the largest BW and Hana system that we
have it's 24 terabytes and bunch of
other Hana systems and be also a
transactional systems I should say
there's a suite on Hana so I the point
being that you know we do have a good
amount of talent in Hana skills and then
as we look at our s4 journey right now
where that's that started that's in in
our UK for the UK implementation that's
a completely green feel net new
implementation so that's starting on GCP
right has already started on GCP when it
comes to North America I think you know
we have to kind of see get that get the
experience with getting our UK
environment on GCP and learn from that
and then take those learnings and bring
them back and you know plan our journey
here yeah so that's where we are just
mostly North America mostly forming
norming stage UK started yeah it's
fascinating for both of you the ultimate
destination is the same which is vector
E in your case one giant s4 system in
your case plate two one for Europe and
one for America but the the the two
journeys are just vastly different right
best thing as it goes so I think one of
the things I mean or since watch people
in the audience who ultimately are
either on the same journey you're on or
or considering the same journey you're
on so I think that's a little bit of
this which is the just couple of
specific questions but one of them is
how do you actually set about evaluating
how do you at the point where it comes
to the okay we've got to pick a cloud
provider how did you set about
evaluating google cloud specifically
don't with others as well how do you set
that decision criteria how do you get
that process together what did you learn
from that yeah I think there's a lot of
factors that went into that we have been
on a cloud journey for a while actually
with you know some other providers but
essentially it all came down to what
Google brought to the table there's you
may have heard our CTO target in the key
note this morning the software
engineering mindset and a mindset of hey
a challenge you know challenging us to
actually think differently because
previously we were all thinking lift and
shift and you know up to my total cost
of ownership optimization and all of
that and we'd were really not moving the
dial forward so with Google coming in
and challenging us on that front and you
know showing that partnership and then
the other side is you know SP the scale
that I just talked about
I mean McKesson everything else around
it will move if SP moves you know so to
be able to because so that became a one
of a big use cases for the evaluation so
last year we did a POC and with Google
and we were able to kind of within a
four to six weeks time frame able to
actually set up ASAP system soup-to-nuts
and test a lot of our operational
capabilities there so that became
actually uh you know I am pretty sure
that became also one of the major inputs
back into the decision-making process
I'm sure there's a lot more that went
into it
but I will say that this was a pretty
big use case I think it's interesting I
mean if I nedd I fundamentally the
feedback from McKesson at the end of it
is you guys entered this and with the
question do you have the boxes and we
exited the question of do you have the
processes right and and that's different
they won't you ever be coming from a
different journey so and we pushing very
hard as I said this omni-channel journey
so we start about two years ago actually
three years ago this wage has to move
into the delivery business or food
delivery business is extremely relevant
first we're growing two-digit percent
every year since then so we are
currently journey more than six billion
already out of delivery business or
quite strong growth to three years and
scalability is a clear issue first so
for example if you are active in a
country like India and you push the
wrong button and you send out a campaign
to I don't know 20 30 million people and
obviously have a scalability question to
solve so and therefore we it was pretty
clear that this cannot be done with our
existing own data centers so we decide
okay let's move into the cloud space
we're looking into that area
just as you mentioned the engineering
perspective is extremely relevant for us
and obviously it's I think it's pretty
clear just looking into this event here
I mean the engineers they simply love
Google so therefore and that was already
kind of a commitment from the
engineering perspective but cost played
a role also and how are we treated when
it comes for example to the negotiations
etc so because this is for me personally
extremely relevant so Google did a
pretty good job and therefore we made
this decision about two years ago to
move our digital products into Google
cloud mainly due to a scalability and
also global scale although just to be
very frank we have some issues here
obviously with China and with Russia so
because Google is not present in these
countries at this point at least so we
hope that something's moving there
hopefully soon but so the announcement
yesterday enters helps us a lot because
if for example I don't know we could
part with a public cloud provider in
China and then there's a nice link using
enter us into into that cloud
environment helps obviously our
operation so therefore this was a
starting point and then when the
migration of s APR 3 2016 2 multi or
hybrid cloud environment or say
on-premise or bringing even a second a
public cloud provider but we made the
decision ok to stick with Google so
therefore we made the decision also to
move there and obviously had some
discussions with Google and we produced
at the beginning a couple of proof of
concepts and people were pretty happy
about it actually very surprising
because initially from our internal
people there was more kind of a pushback
witnessed when we said ok we moved to a
public cloud also on sa P space now so
because the feedback was ok now we want
to have our own boxes and everything
under control but we said we started a
couple of proof of concepts they were
extremely easy and so and the initial
proof of contact initially was planned
to do it in 2 to 3 months and we didn't
it I don't know in one or two weeks so
and that convinced obviously also our
tech people and the ICP guys and
therefore the decision was pretty clear
I think we met
sapphire last year so that was me last
year and we said hey you know we think
we can do this I remember the time
they're like ok let's give it a go and
and yeah let me hear 16 weeks later we
concluded it all out and we're
proceeding forward I mean that's
lightning
speed in a cpworld but anyway I mean and
so in full disclosure I mean these are
massive projects right they're gonna go
on for years so we're just give us a
sign someone you know so in your case
you being right now for like six months
you've been run for six weeks
basically effectively since we flew the
first boxes to use we just want to give
us update on where you are and what
you've learned so far
yes is that the the technology actually
is not the problem it's it's more to
consolidate and harmonize the different
process across a different country so we
spend quite a lot of time in convincing
people and come to a standard approach
because obviously you have a couple of
CFO's from the countries i want to have
a different setup of the ICP environment
so therefore a lot of conceptual work
convincing these guys that it makes
sense to go into one standard approach
which obviously huge implications on the
processes in the individual countries
but there we are and we're in the middle
of the implementation right now are we
doing and this is historically within
Metro we're doing a lot of the stuff
ourselves so we're building up now huge
resources in India to customize and
implement s ApS for Hana so and this is
ongoing and we're hiring every couple of
days a couple of people and just make
sure that we have a good s AP practice
in-house and using not too many partners
to do this but obviously get a lot of
support from SMP directly and also
obviously from Google as you mention our
journey is very recent in terms of
actually process I think we have good
you know alignment from the
standardization and harmonization
perspective but that's not happened
overnight either so that's been a long
journey your journey started way before
yeah a way before actually it started I
think like three or four years ago in
Europe so where they started the
implementation of ECC for that was the
intent that you know and that started in
Norway and that just completed I think
sometime mid of last year and then it
was paused and then you know the pivot
to s4 over there so from a process
perspective I think you know we were
good when we started our technical kind
of evaluation for where it's going to be
deployed so yeah so it is very recent so
far I think the the speed at which we've
been able to do
Boyd even the development environments
they're not sandbox they're actually
developing environments you know the
time line was very aggressive that was
given to us considering that we did a
POC with Google completed concluded that
only last November and we were told that
that all the entire development stack
and systems have to be both by me so so
that was a pretty tall order but so far
I think with the partnership with Google
all the the engineering teams that have
been brought them to work with our
internal teams to enable the platform
and get our deployments going I think
that's been an amazing experience for us
and the ability you know to actually
upskill some of the teams that have been
working you know that's going to be
actually so their independence the
self-reliance aspect of it is also very
important so that's been also sort of
achieved in a short or you know in the
short duration so overall I would say so
far so good
time will tell I'm gonna I'm gonna ask
the team Oh question and come back to
that point you just made but team oh
I've heard you say this a couple of
times I think it's fascinating for the
audience which is the the part of this
for you isn't just I mean the technology
changed in Georgia but it's actually
changing the culture Metro and
partnering with Google was as much of a
change in the culture as it was the
technology you want to kind of explain
that so and like most others probably
also in the room maybe we have this war
for talent so we're really looking
actively for a lot of people and we
started our digital journey with a lot
of externals helping us to build up
these platforms and we know in the
middle of internalization that and you
know if you have people in your
organization that are working for Metro
since I don't know 20 30 40 years it's
and we really have people working more
than 40 years for us which is already a
bit strange to me at least but you you
talk to these people and obviously you
see that they are kind of well fixed on
a specific mindset and to change this
it's obviously good to have an impact
also from the outside world so we get
this push a bit also from from people
like Google so therefore we're sending
people to the Google office as we try to
do work serve together we run in a
couple of innovation labs currently with
Google
so therefore this helps us a lot in at
least driving that space but into that
in that innovation direction but when it
comes to culture it's a bit even more so
we even did a rebranding of our IT
subsidiary so it was former called metro
systems which is obviously not sexy now
called metronome and we combined a
couple of organizations into that
organization and you know if you if you
walk across our campus at headquarters
you see a lot of people wearing
metronome hoodies and t-shirts etc and
that was two or three years ago
impossible and therefore we're pushing
very very hard on brand experience or we
want to be just a good employer brand
and there are very aggressive on that
topic I do a lot of internal service
with our people and actually we do this
on a monthly basis or not on an annual
survey basis just to figure out how well
we're treating the people and they're
investing quite a lot and in terms of
that obviously a partner like Google
helps us a lot because I mean I think
Google is known for having an
exceptional culture and we don't want to
copy the Google culture I think that's
impossible with our setup but at least
there are some things to learn and also
when it comes to hiring processes and
all these HR processes I were just
looking in what Google is doing and
there's a very strong relationship and
what we're doing now since about a year
introducing objectives and key results
or Kairos which is pretty famous at
Google and I think if you talk to the
founders of Google they they at least
tell you that oak house was one of the
the key principles at Google to drive
this organization so there's a lot of
exchange and we're learning a lot from
Google and therefore it's more about
yeah exchanging culture exchanging
processes rather than only having a
technology collaboration yeah I think
one things you said was that basically
every time the Google guys are sitting
there every time the Google guys came to
visit Metro and during the service
process they're always wearing Google
t-shirts as well things that really
resonated for Metro is that they were
very proud of the brand and they want to
display it and then your own people
start to replicate that and it's just
it's a really interesting conversation
because we're having this yesterday I
mean anything you do with a CP is
hopefully a long-term marriage right
multiple ways there's partners there's a
CPE there's us as everything involved so
on the one hand it's a long term I on
the other hand I mean ultimately you
want us to be electricity service right
mean ultimately
on us you want to go to SCP and turn it
on and it works in the updates and it
does everything and and so it's a it's a
little bit of a challenge finally for me
as we look at the business corner which
is what do you really want from us
because on the one hand what you want is
stability and effectively never to have
to talk to us because the stuff just
runs on the other hand we do have the
maintain contact and we do have to grow
together and so if you have a concept
I'm interested right but it's a it's a
long-term chance for me which is what is
it you actually after the sale is done
right what is it you actually want from
us in a long-term relationship to make
actually be successful in the long term
I think you just nailed it because we
consider at least in that context I mean
when I talk about digital and talking
about warehouse management and I think
it's a different topic or supply chain
as other examples but we're in current
when it comes to financial services and
financial processes internally it simply
needs to run it needs to be up and
running so therefore the example you
just brought with electricity or water
that's what we're expecting from you
making sure that this works and that it
runs without any hassle and that it
provides good scalability that security
is fine so that nobody's stealing stuff
from us so that's our requirement at
this point but as I said long term I
could imagine that we that we're driving
this relationship between Google s AP
and Metro even to the next level and
then we have a bit of a more demand
because then it comes into innovation
that we are talking about new things
that we deployed with specific countries
that we have also on this cultural level
some exchange so this is what we expect
him but at this point when it comes to
the finance applications it's all about
making sure that it works in a proper
way and that it runs smooth for our
customers and I'm talking about internal
customers so therefore I simply don't
want to get any stress with the CFO's in
the country so it's just want to hear
from them and I don't know one or two or
three years when we're done with that
process and that it works smooth and
that they don't have any problems at all
because it's good as a CIO that if you
hear nothing then it's perfect and
that's what I would like to achieve and
me now I think you equally I mean we're
at the start of the journey with
McKesson obviously you and me were in
Stuttgart five weeks ago and we started
this process where we basically the the
the road track for you is we did a
hackathon basically where we had our
team and your team together especially I
mean
I think three hours into the hackathon
my team was elbowed out of the way and
your guys to go for it was a amazing
process but again is that how are you
gonna build that I guess internally in
McKesson to get the transitional change
to happen and then how do you think the
long term works yeah I think essentially
that was the start of it
you know the hackathon that you talked
about just to get that you know base
excited you know it's it's an amazing
thing to watch when they actually get to
do this themselves literally after even
after that week I think there's so much
of feedback I've gotten from that team
that they felt so empowered just going
through that process and being able to
actually you know ACP I know it can be
pretty you know mundane in terms of you
know technology and all of that it's you
know pretty pretty you know it has a
long history but but just to be able to
use the cloud capabilities to be able to
build some level of automation that we
built even that we can we continue to
kind of hone on more and more I think
that is exciting people there and also
on top of that now our go forward
strategy is let SP do what it's best for
and then anything else you know anything
you know differentiating capabilities
that you want to build for your
competitive advantage in the market take
it out don't build there and so that is
also gonna give the team's an
opportunity to actually learn new new
skills and they may not become
developers overnight and use the but but
there is definitely a desire there when
you start to paint that picture you know
so you have to give them those
opportunities to be able to cross skill
as well and that's what we have focused
on as well you know there are a lot of
you know teams that do that type of work
so we are trying to see where there is
interest within the existing teams and
help them get plugged into those air
groups and and get some experience
working on some of those projects
the other thing is what we've been doing
also like a almost like a shark tank
kind of concept where we've been
pitching letting people put some ideas
about what they want to do on the cloud
platform and you know kind of of course
it has to have some eventual you know
some value that we are going to
eventually deliver but those are the
ideas we are getting from people and
from the teams and then we are picking a
couple to invest and let them work on it
so I mean all of this you know is really
helping kind of build that excitement
and obviously you know and then it
attracts talent external talent as well
and so yeah so there's a lot of things
we are trying to do in that to energize
the team's there right cool so I guess
two final questions one of which is
incredibly dangerous because there's a
camera in the back that I'm recording
this and B I'm gonna ask the question
that the the general rules say never ask
this question but the what for me
personally one of my personal things
always just writing a feedback it's like
yeah I like the nice things tell me what
we need to do better right it's all
about improvement and I said one of my
team actually recently asked me how they
were doing you do great they're like
yeah tell me about what I need to do
better I'm like okay like that attitude
in that spirit what do you need us to do
better what can we what can we do more
for you as we go forwards here so I
think well our journeys recent so I
think we'll you know we'll continue to
discover but I think our goal is really
to learn from your teams and then get
get complete not if not completely but
fair you know have a fair amount of self
independence so we want you know Google
to take that approach with us as well
focus more on you know how we can learn
and you know so that's one thing and
then continue to you know challenge our
mindset continue to do that because
sometimes we can be fixated in you know
some things and so continue to do that
and
you know that's been very for me that's
been something I've seen and I hope to
continue to see yeah one of the
feedbacks we've heard loud and hard from
customers is we need to start doing
customer panels and customer
get-togethers and start sharing and your
drive in that community in knowledge
better it's clearly one things we have
to do I got it Timo I'm sure you have
feedback yeah and you get the chance to
speak it out loud yeah sure so and I
could repeat a couple of things you just
mentioned but one topic we would like to
see a bit more as a more business talk
so because I mean at the end Google is a
very engineering driven organization
which is fine and actually our engineers
love the way Google is doing business
but now from a top management
perspective it would be it just nice to
get a bit more support and a bit more
insights when it comes to the business
related functions so therefore we highly
appreciate what just has been
communicated in the in the the meetings
the keynote meetings yesterday and today
that these industry specific solutions
that will be developed by Google and by
partners so this is something we're
really looking forward to so because as
I said our business is not a classical
retail business so we're really looking
for to get more innovation into our
organization etc and therefore we
expecting that from a strategic partner
like Google and sa P that we're getting
a bit more feedback and bit more
consultancy when it comes to business
specific questions we might have and
also what you just mentioned custom
panels etc so exchange with other peers
would be very helpful but well building
industry specific solutions for the
retail industry that fit also our
specific needs that would be just
perfect so because so far excellent
technology no question about that and is
also a computer science guy appreciate
that in keynotes there are some unique
shelves and you see some commands type
in but obviously I would like to see a
bit more more business talk in the
future and that's our requirement cool
and so clock is running down last
question
the you're on a journey there's a lot of
people sitting audience or probably
thinking yeah I'm gonna have to do the
same thing some of there's some people
in this audience are thinking I want to
do the same thing and there's some
people in already so thinking I have to
do the same thing whether I want it or
not right
knowing what you know now what's your
best advice to them it's actually quite
simple so just make sure that you take
the team with you
that would be my major advice so it was
not a top-down decision that we say okay
let's let's move
into the Google cloud environment we
really asked our people we got really
some buy-in we'd build a lot of
prototypes so if you have the buy-in
from your team and your organization
then it's actually a fairly easy move so
but if you do it top-down and say ok I
mean I don't know if everybody would be
a huge Microsoft friend and then we make
the decision towards Google then this
would be a disaster but in our case we
we simply informed the people up front
we asked for their opinion and just made
sure that that we have a lot of proof of
concept and I just got the buy-in from
the team and if you have that then it's
an easy-going so I mean we're not
through yet so I'm expecting obviously
in the next couple of months and years
some issues within the project which is
pretty normal but I know that the team
is highly motivated and I know when we
first communicated in the ICP space that
we're moving towards cloud we got a huge
pushback but then when they guys saw the
technology and could play around with
the technology it was fairly easy for
them and therefore we have now well
transform basically our sa P guys from
on-premise fans into Google fans and
this obviously helps to run such a huge
project
cool very similar so that's that's you
know for us it had to be a little bit of
a top-down as well because I think you
know that's also needed because people
are looking for that prescriptive
direction and as well at a time so
that's helped so it's both ways
energizing our you know it's the
bottom-up and top-down approach that's
really worked well for us and then the
other thing is don't think too much get
started you know and you know it's ok to
fail fast try things out and you will
not know until you actually try things
out and there's a lot to learn and we've
you know not like I mentioned McKesson
has been on this cloud journey for a
while but it will take some time so so
start think well start but then go slow
in terms of you know you have to really
pace it out in terms of you know what
you want to achieve so I think that's
that's at least what what I see has been
working for us thanks I'll tell you it's
one of those for me is you know we are
30 second provisioning globally for any
SUV system it's all per second billing
all the way up towards our fleet so
unlike a classic SDB project where
you know you start thinking about it
this year you're gonna size it out you
get sticker shock you put it in the
budget you maybe do it next year you can
do this this afternoon on a credit card
right and it's that that that adjusting
to the remove Monteux striction x' is
kind of hard right I think right back to
start the conversation it's it's not
about the technology it's about the
process and once you're understand
what's possible you can go from there
8 thank you for your time we're spend
the time with us this afternoon Timo
Mena sincerely appreciate you giving us
insight and wisdom and spend the time
with us really appreciate it
like I said you can go this afternoon
and start an SUV server in 30 seconds
that's never been done before at scale
there's no reason not to give it a go in
the mean time I will tell you the next
organizers would dearly appreciate if
you provide feedback on the session so
we know what you liked and what you
didn't like and and what we should do
next year but at all rate of growth and
SCP I think there'll be a few more
release to come in the next as we go
forward so thanks your time and my last
call actually had to say is if you're
interested at all why wait
yes the Andes Sydney we had a
conversation around Sydney and Andy's
West and they a similar question his
answer was tell me exactly what your
plan B is right because if plan E is
wait and see if anything if I need to do
this at some point you're gonna have to
change right and so if it is this simple
and it is this possible why are we all
waiting right competitive advantages on
your site if you do it and if you want
to do that
call me well will more than happily come
out and visit you but thank you all team
off thank you one more time
[Music]